what is flight tonight flight tonight is
all about trying to figure out a
destination that you can fly at the last
minute for cheap money so it used to be
the case you could turn up at the
airport with your bags and go somewhere
fun but the airlines are doing a great
job of pricing those last-minute tickets
way up there there still are these
bargains and so we made this app to say
you know if you're in New York you want
to take off tonight we'll help you find
a cheap place to go so you aggregate all
of the data and that exists across all
the different airlines yeah what hopper
does we actually watch billions of
flight prices every day and crunch those
numbers so that we can bring some
transparency to how the prices work and
in process of doing that we find deals
and these last-minute destinations in
real time alright so the deals include
for example I noticed the Trinidad
Honolulu Aruba for example all of these
places are expended on a relatively
inexpensive yeah exactly you can get to
Hawaii right now last minute for seven
hundred dollars there's some amazing
sales if you want to wait a little bit
longer you can get there for 570 right
now from New York Trinidad I noticed 265
Honolulu 700 if you'd like to get some
warm weather Aruba 372 in Charleston
maybe 276 yeah exactly are the
restrictions associated with all these
no these are just seats that the
airline's haven't been able to yield to
the you know the high price at the last
minute and it's a different destination
on any given day from any given airport
but we'll help you find what they are
all right so let's say that you've got
your act together a little bit more than
to do last minute and you're planning
your thanksgiving holiday maybe even
your winter your Christmas break what
are some of the things we ought to know
so the interesting thing we found with
Thanksgiving travel is that the you know
the airline's know that you have no
flexibility you've got to get to your
in-laws on that particular day and so
you don't have a lot of flex prices
start high but they stay flat so you
don't have to book that much in advance
you can wait till 10 days before and
you're still getting pretty much the
same price right what about for winter
holidays for Christmas right and I think
they're people have more flexibility so
around the Christmas period you really
have to book before Halloween to get in
there before the prices really start to
ramp up so you got again before
trick-or-treating in order to go skiing
let's say exactly right right you and
that's what hopper is really all about
helping you find those bargains you can
shop your particular trip and we'll tell
you how much other people are paying for
it